so again i want to
yeah briefly show you
what will happen
once you are registered
okay so
let's say for example you are interested
in biomedical data analysis using r and
python
yes great question right girl how do you
know so this is a page where
again i'll just go to my profile
so this is my profile and you see that
under badges i have a number of programs
that i have been added to
and i also have a starter subscription
so once you pre-register right the
preview registration was when you filled
out the form and you said you know i'm
from this university this is my degree
this is which program i would like to
join once you fill out that form you are
now ready for registration and then
jabs or someone else will reach out to
you
ask specific questions if you do qualify
you will receive an email so you have
between now and june 15th to be fully
registered
and how do you know that you have been
registered you've received an email and
for that please make sure that you have
our contacts in your contact book so
that they're not going to spam
those include hello at pine.bio
support at pion.bio
so they're all going to be uh pine.pio
accounts and they will notify you that
you have been accepted
and then you will see a
badge right here
with the description of the program that
you are
in
and you will get a starter subscription
so if you go to your profile again how
do you get to your profile you go in the
menu and click on your email address
and then you will see a program page
and the program page this is a program
page that i am not a part of
so here you will still request more
information or start your application if
you scroll down you will see here
uh pricing but if you have been accepted
you're not going to see pricing anymore
and i will show you that in a second but
this is an example of a program page it
has
a schedule of sessions
in each session you have additional
resources that you can complete
and um it's got a full overview of these
right here on top
if i go to a page
where i have uh
where i'm already a member of that uh
program you know i'll just go to this
one
uh in here i am already a member so i
will see it like this
and here you can see that i see my
personal progress
i have access to the coursework
and instead of just seeing a schedule i
see the session video if it already
passed that's the previous one or for
future ones i will see a zoom link and i
can click on that zoom link and i
actually participate in that zoom on the
specific date and time
so here
i can also complete sessions and once i
complete them
once i complete all of them
i will get the certificate um
for
completing that program
any other questions
okay so if you qualify through lbrn do
you register for the classes via ilab
for hana i think that is uh for you
i think for lbr ren
you actually
uh yes for lbrn
um
you would have to go to
[Music]
this link
to this registration link
again this is just for people who are
from lbirn
and once you submit this
form you will be you will
be evaluated by uh dr ramesh dubromanian
uh who is the
program coordinator and he will
or director and he
if you are approved then you will
receive an email notification from
either ramos subramanian for hana
or john cubito
okay
you just joined we had a full webinar
already we're just about to
um
by when are you supposed to get there
okay sorry for hana um
foreign would you like to go over this
thing again
yeah can you repeat the question
the q there are two questions so the
first one is if we qualify through lvrn
do we register for the classes via ilab
and the second one was by when are we
supposed to get the notification
okay so if you are part of the lvrn
the the form that you can see right now
here on the screen is the red cap
application
form i guess yeah so
just fill out this and your if you are
approved
you will be notified by the by john i
guess
so there they have some criteria it's
it's uh
the registration is free for a limited
number of uh vrn members so not all of
them are members will be
actually
getting the
free registration
offer
so
john and ramesh will be
looking at your application and
if you qualify then you will be approved
and they will notify you and if you are
approved you will get an email from me
uh explaining the ilab registration
process so so far i already got 20
approved lprn members either faculty or
staff or students
so they i i guess the registration
process is over but you can still
contact and try to
fill out this form see whether they have
any
any more spots available so yes first
free registration through this
registration form and then
fill out the forms in ilab
to get your registration completed so
two steps